foreign
good morning
it being 10 o'clock we'll start on time
this is the organizational meeting of
the finance committee the house finance
committee New Hampshire Constitution
gives us a unique role because we're
closer to the people so all spending
bills must originate in the New
Hampshire house and the New Hampshire
house has designated us
as the finance committee to do that task
budget by law can can only contain
spreadsheets
and you'll see that in the orientation
so hb2 is added we call it the the
trailer bill it has to describe all the
changes that enable the legislation such
if we put in new legislation or if we
um
changes the law changed the tax all that
has to go in hp2
so
when we get that
um
the budget's usually about 1500 pages
thick and last time the hb2 was over 300
Pages it's the biggest we've seen in my
25 years of looking at it usually it's a
hundred and some pages but last year
three over 300.
if this policy changes I send those off
to a policy committee for for uh
comments and then they'd come back to
Western we'd act appropriately we have
about six weeks to accomplish the task
of completing the budget so it's it's a
pretty full-time thing we'll be meeting
Monday through Friday
um because of the room shortage and the
spreading out and so on Health and Human
Services has been assigned to this room
as well
they'll be using it mostly Wednesdays
and hopefully they'll use a full day so
they won't have to go into other days so
it'll be it'll be hours
Monday Tuesday Thursday Friday and of
course your committee rooms except for
division three is is a little different
this year
I'm sorry I gotta pay a fine on that one
foreign
okay
so I owe now
five dollars for my
my S uh phone going off while we're
having a hearing
Okay so
we have a February 15th the governor
will deliver to us if he's on time hp1
he'll come in here and and
make a Spiel and then leave and leave to
his budget expert
who's never done this before so I'm
pleased to have all the experience we
have in this room
to work on that budget we'll go up line
by line Page by Page we'll compare it
with what they spent last year we might
ask a comment
was that successful did it cover
everything was it more than you needed
they'll never admit it or was it less
than you needed and did we do anything
in the law to make it a bigger project
project than it was previously
we have the ability to shift funds from
one line to another with some exceptions
we try to keep Personnel lines separate
because that's where they quite often
come in and we've done some work thanks
to my vice chair and I looking at
other ways to count the number of
employees I asked the treasurer this
year for a list of paychecks so don't
come in and tell me you have 800
employees when only 700 paychecks went
out so it's it's another way to
cross-check that we're going down the
right road because everybody likes to
put a little
extra list of people in there and then
come into us later and do a song and
dance well you know
we'd like to give a few
uh pay raises to some people or maybe
everybody and we'll say
we only have so much money in that line
well you know we had a lot of early
retirement so there's a little extra
money in there well isn't that odd you
started with extra people in there that
you didn't have so we do our best to
find them and take them out because we
don't want everybody to have a little
slush fund if you need extra money come
to us we may find it in another agency
but don't expect every agency to have
their own slush fund so we have to find
that and take it out
so
you may have noticed that the house
appreciates this task that we do for
them and that's why we have so much room
we have more room than others as I
started to say normally we have the two
division rooms across the hall and
division three would use this room and
they're down to their their usual
I think it'd be eight people and uh and
they'd have a big room for all the
people that come in from HHS because
that's the half of the budget they deal
with so
because the Health and Human Services
may be here Wednesdays
I've asked to give them the room
downstairs 104. so division three may
meet in 104 sometime it's also been
assigned to several of these
extra committees that have been created
on housing and and so on that may also
be meeting there sometimes so
so Monday Tuesday Thursday Friday
division
three may meet here sometimes the other
times they'll probably be meeting down
at 104.
depending on how the room what rooms are
available but it's nice for them to have
a special room like all the other
divisions
so
we now have about 11 bills that come
directly to us
for the for the first committee some of
them invite vacated by other committees
for instance the one hb50 relative to
payment of the state of a portion of
retirement system contributions to
political subdivisions was vacated by
Edna so it's come to us and I think
there's another one from
education that dealt with the difference
between five thousand and twenty
thousand when they had to have a special
meeting so they vacated that that's
really a financial decision rather than
any policy so we're taking some of those
bills up front will probably deal with
those
hopefully before we start the budget
work on the 15th so
um
first meeting for us I'd like to
introduce ourselves a little tell a
little bit about ourselves I'll start
MIT graduate went right in the Air Force
to Pilot training
um had six years of active duty decided
I liked uh flying airplanes more than
doing chemical engineering although
there was some relationship
and went on to Airlines as well as the
Air Force Reserve and spent 38 years in
my flying career I've been in the
legislature since 1990 I've been on the
finance committee or it's or it's
predecessor Appropriations since 94 I
think I had one term I was not on this
committee since that time and uh
I've enjoyed the work uh it's a
challenge for us to figure out how to
make everything work and and
I quite often rely on alternative
sources sometimes the people that come
before us tell one story if you happen
to know or have a neighbor that works
there you might hear a different story
or if you run into somebody so sit down
and talk with those people and you'll
find out lots of things that we may not
find out in in these rooms so use your
outside connections to find out
everything you can and it will come in
handy and then another thing that uh
I'm proud to have his this group of
geniuses we call a legislative budget
assistant
they will they've got lots of years of
experience in each of our divisions uh
Michael Kane I I consider him kind of
the dean of the college because he
trains all these people as does his his
uh right-hand guy Chris then the other
state agency steal them away and you
will hear us sometimes greet people that
we have seen before come before us in
various divisions we've got to see it
over here for you Jess
and you know and and find out about what
they're doing in their new in their new
job but they're used to talking to
legislatures they learn the steps and so
on by this Dean of the college so anyway
um Janet Clayman is is
a rare thing to have a full-time
committee assistant most committees have
to share them
but respect her space
uh we all going to contribute twenty
dollars for the goodies she stocks in
the back room
uh more if we need it but so we'll all
have coffee and goodies when you come
for a break
but respect her space don't sit at her
her desk or try to use her computer
those are not for you we have rooms some
places in the back so all right I've
introduced myself my vice chair Keith
will go on go ahead and we'll move them
down that side and then up this side
I'm Keith irf uh Vice chair of Finance I
don't have quite the broad
background that representative Weiler
laid out for us this is my third term in
the finance committee uh prior to that
and even currently I have my own
computer software uh business and I'm
looking forward to getting through the
Mary Jane walner and I'm from Concord
I've this will be my 22nd term in the
house and I've served on children and
family law Health and Human Services
for a couple years a couple terms I was
the majority leader
and I have been on finance most of
almost all the rest of the time that
I've been here I love I love working on
division three and working on the Health
and Human Service budget
as a profession I ran a Child Care
Agency for close to 50 years and
um feel very very committed to Children
and Families in New Hampshire and really
look forward to working with all of you
good morning uh
I had to laugh when Mary Jane said she
took care of younger people she's in the
perfect spot here taking care of me but
anyway so
my name is Peter leishman uh
this will be I think my eighth term on
finance
um I'm from Peterborough
and let's see
um what are you telling everybody what
how many terms you've served on
different committees and that sort of
thing yeah what you do on the outside
okay
um
so I've been in the uh house 12 terms so
I still have a way to go to catch up
with Mary Jane but I served on
environment and agriculture uh election
law
and Judiciary and uh
I have a wonderful wife a grandchild on
the way so that's all good news so I
guess that's about it looking forward to
hi all my name is Dan McGuire I'm from
Epsom and this is my fourth term both in
the legislature and on this committee
although I serve for three terms and
then took another three terms off
and decided to come back
my wife is in her eighth term and so uh
I I follow what's going on and and uh
I know that we're part of the best
legislative body in the country there's
no no question about it and so I look
hi everyone my name is Mary Heath and
I've been in the legislature since
2013. I came in on a special election
and I served one year on Health and
Human Services two terms on House Ed and
this is going to be my third
session on finance I always serve on
division two because I'm an educator by
trade was a teacher special ed teacher
worked as administrator as well also
served at the New Hampshire Department
of Education
so I'm happy to be here and it's always
a pleasure to work with everyone I
I'm Jerry Griffin
um I'm basically a financial guy but
like I had shaman
I served in the Air Force I'm a Vietnam
veteran I was a aircraft maintenance
officer took care of the c-130s in
Vietnam
um when I came out of Vietnam I got my
MBA I sat for the CPA exam kind of
changed careers
and uh became a Chief Financial Officer
for private companies
I took one company private and I took
one company public
I'm retired at this point I own the New
Hampshire license plate Museum it keeps
me pretty busy
uh and this is my uh third term I tell
people I've won four elections but one
of them I was reversed in a recount I
went from winning by 22 votes to losing
by eight that was quite a shock
but uh my first term was 2016 and I'm
why is that doesn't work yeah that's
better thank you Jerry
uh my name is David Hewitt I'm from
Laconia
this is my fifth non-consecutive term in
the in the House of Representatives and
my fourth term on the finance committee
um I started out I graduated from Saint
Anselm College and from the Georgetown
University Law Center and practice law
on Laconia
in 1970 it was my first time I ran for
the house and was elected served two
terms then then but the law practice got
so busy that I really didn't have time
for it anymore so I got out
and further time passed and I wound up
uh I got appointed judge of the Laconia
District Court I served there for 30
years the year I got out I went down to
City Hall and filed for the legislature
again
uh and I've been doing it ever since now
of course Laconia is not a not a
democratic stronghold so uh it comes and
goes
I've always enjoyed working on the
finance committee there's a there are a
lot of good people that work on on this
committee and I'm looking forward for
another great great term this year thank
you
foreign
bean I come from Guilford this is my
I live on his piece of property that my
family's own since 1842
and um
I just got a great grandson he's Harry
being the sixth
um
I'm gonna do the best I can do on on
good morning my name is Karen Ebel I
come from New London I represent New
London and Newbury this is my sixth term
in the legislature I spent my first five
terms on public works and highways so
spent a lot of time on the capital
budget and the 10-year Transportation
plan I was born and raised in Ossipee my
roots don't go quite as far back as
yours but I went to school originally
for biology and biochemistry at Trinity
College in Vermont I then ended up at
Georgetown Law Center where I studied
law met my husband practice law
corporate law for several years saw the
light and returned back where we raised
our family in New London I didn't
practice law after that I spent almost
20 years in the planning board a lot of
volunteer work and and now I'm in the
legislature and the legislature is my
life
hi I'm Laura tolerski I represent
nashua's Ward 8. this is my third term
my first two terms I served on house
transportation
I grew up in Nashua went on to
Georgetown University where I got my
undergraduate degree and then I also
have a degree from the University of
Chicago where I got my masters
and after moving around with my husband
who I met at the University of Chicago
we settled again in Nashua on the same
street I grew up in and I've been busy
raising my three kids I still have two
in college
and I am looking forward to spending the
next six weeks with all of you here in
foreign
Hall from Dunbarton this would be my
fifth term non-consecutive in 2016 I had
started an engineering firm and after
finishing out that session in 17 and 18
I took time off to grow the engineering
firm
um this is my first term on finance
prior sessions I was on House Education
thank you I'm Jerry Stringham I'm a
graduate of MIT like our steam chairman
but also Harvard Business School I spent
12 years as a serial entrepreneur
developing Medical Technology I've been
in healthcare my entire career after 12
years I had a couple of young children
and switched over to Consulting I
started a consulting firm about 25 years
ago that's worked with over 200
manufacturers of innovative medical
Technologies seen some great
Technologies and great companies develop
particular expertise I have is in the
health care reimbursement system which
every new technology needs to understand
I'm in my
second term here I served on Ways and
Means from 2018 to 2020 and from Lincoln
and looking forward to serving on
um I'm Sharon nordgren I represent
Hanover and lime
and uh I was first elected in
1988. I spent the first few terms on
what was called children youth and
families
following Mary Jane who was also on that
committee I joined her then on what was
called the Appropriations Committee we
met in room 100 over in the state house
and I've always been on what you would
call Division III Health Newman Services
committee
foreign
so I'm representative Mary heck and
Phillips I represent Grafton County
District 12 along with Sharon
um so that's Hanover and lime
let's see last term I served on ways and
means so I'm looking forward to seeing
the other side of the equation here
um
let's see I'm an attorney by trade I'm
not currently practicing but I also have
a background in the financial industry
in Chicago
prior to going to law school so I bring
a little bit of knowledge with me today
and I'm just very pleased to join you
all and I look forward to you know
hello I'm Daniel Popovich Miller I'm
representing Windham I'm a freshman so
I'm new to absolutely everything in the
state house and around the state house
I'm a naturalized citizen too coming
from Romania which used to be a
communist country so there is that
I was also on the Wyndham School Board
which trust me there is no more
unpleasant sort of election in the
School Board elections in Windham the
general Camp you know the general court
elections have nothing on that
I'm an engineer by trade originally I
never really practiced I worked for a
startup in my country until we left and
moved to the US because my wife got
accepted to Dartmouth College so I hung
around the Upper Valley for six years
and I loved that part of the you know
state
um I got my uh bu of an MBA from bu I
used to have a CPA license until I
stopped maintaining my CPE requirements
during the covid years so that's
technically no longer valid but I did
hold it for a while I taught for a
living for about 10 years technical
training classes certified novel
instructor and Microsoft trainer I then
went to work as a database developer and
software developer for a few years then
I got my MBA and I ended up in
government Finance with Praxair which
where I ran the finances for the
healthcare DV you know that gave me a
lot of insight into that particular
industry and then I was the finance
director for the town of Wyndham for six
years and a half which ended this June
exactly three days before the end of the
filing period which gave me that
wonderful opportunity to jump right back
in and sort of you know win my seat as
you know the first time house rep I
really appreciate your patience I know
there is a lot but as I said I'm brand
new and I'd rather do it once for
everybody so thank you for the
good morning I'm Kate Murray I'm from
Newcastle and represent Newcastle and
Ward 5 in Portsmouth which is generally
considered the south end one of the more
historic areas of Portsmouth I have
doctoral degrees in music and in
Theology and taught at UCLA until kiddos
came along and my husband went computer
sciencey
um this is my
third term on finance I've been in the
house for four terms I first serve on
criminal justice after that I moved to
finance to finance here which I have
loved it becomes if those of you who
have been here already know this those
of you who are coming on will learn
quickly it becomes pretty much your
second family
it's a challenging a really fun really
interesting committee to be on so thank
you
good morning my name is Jose cambrells I
represent the towns of Canterbury and
Louden I'm a retired engineering
executive from BAE Systems this will be
my second term I served on science
technology and energy the last session
and I am very honored to been uh have
been accepted onto the finance committee
on my numbers and spreadsheet type of
guy so I think I'll fit in very well
Excuse me yes good morning my name is
Tom Buco I currently serve as a state
representative for Carroll County
District number one which which is the
town of Conway
um I I spent many years in the
construction industry as a as an iron
worker and a welder and then I went back
to college and got a Bachelor's degree
in Business Administration from
I I've been I've run
I've run for office 10 times and been
elected nine times
so you can see I don't catch on too
quick
keep coming back for more
um on my first term I served on public
works and highways and learned about the
capital budget and worked on the 10-year
Transportation plan
and since then I've served on how on
this finance committee and in which I
served one term each on um
division three and also division one
um but in the last this will be my
eighth term on division two and I really
enjoy working on the budgets for
Department of Transportation and safety
and education and also Des
well good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is
Maureen Mooney and I'm from the town of
Merrimack that's Hillsborough County
number 12. I'm currently in my fifth
term here in the New Hampshire house
though like many of you they haven't
been consecutive I was in from 2002 to
2008 and then reelected again in 2020.
so I've gotten to see all angles of the
legislature during that time I served on
Judiciary and on the rules committee
this will be my first full term on
finance I was reassigned to finance last
term Midway through so I have a great
introduction to the committee and to the
people and I get I look forward to
working with all of you as I serve on
division three this time around thank
you
oh and one more thing if you don't mind
I apologize for the interruption of
coming in and out I have a bill to
introduce and Judiciary originally
scheduled for 10 30. turns out they're
half an hour behind so it looks like
I'll be leaving again at 11. so please
good morning my name is Tracy Emrick I'm
from Hampton this is my fifth term my
first term was in labor and then I went
on I've been on finance ever since of
course I did take a vacation for two
years like many other people
education they have a bachelor's degree
in philosophy an MBA and a PhD in
business I was self-employed with the
database marketing company for many
years and of late I've decided to
publish I've got two books on Amazon one
was written about two decades ago but I
don't know how it re-emerged it's a
business book and now I've got a
motivational book that for sale online
I didn't know that about you and uh I I
don't have anything to sell today uh I
wish I did I I'm I'm Jess Edwards uh
this is my uh fourth term they've been
uh consecutive I'm blessed to live in a
very favorable District so you're never
going to get rid of me uh sorry uh I I I
want to point out uh Jerry Stringham uh
didn't mention that he's the clerk of
division three uh Sharon nordgren is our
ranking member of division three Maureen
Mooney is our vice chair of division
three and and this will be the second
term I've at least had an opportunity to
start out chairing division three I I uh
a fun fact about me I'm the only person
in U.S military history as a hospital
administrator to have established a
combat arms Training Center are in a
hostile fire zone so it's all it teaches
me and taught me was you know anything
that happens in the legislature is
relatively easy compared to that uh I I
spent my career in healthcare
administration I had an opportunity to
be on the faculty at Georgetown for a
little while
I wrote just a textbook chapter on
Military telemedicine half my career was
in the military half of it was in
hospitals and medical device
manufacturers so so I think I'm in a
good spot in terms of my background
because it's been combined with being on
HHS oversight Governor's Commission on
alcohol and drug abuse the telemedicine
commission and a few other things so so
I've been blessed to have kind of a
holistic opportunity to to view our
State Health Care system so
good morning thank you Mr chairman I'm
Joe Petry I represent Stratford district
one which is Farmington
I started out in the military working on
airplanes
or guys like our chairman
and uh you know I didn't like that well
I spent probably
oh I don't know 10 years or so doing
that and I also worked I cross-trained
in a crypto which is electronics and
that was that was fun
uh
I I worked at the shipyard Electronics
technician and I decided to go in
business for myself in construction and
uh that worked out I'm very active in my
town government I've I live on the same
property that I grew up on which uh that
was 77 years ago give or take
but uh going to the uh again to division
two I spent this is my seventh term
and I spent many uh
great days in education with some of you
and uh
two terms in education and then the
other five terms here in finance uh
division two which is uh it's a great
place we got good uh
we got good budgets for uh great things
and uh you know education is probably
one of my passions
uh I got uh let me see
I got nine grandkids four kids
and a great wife 55 years worth
thank you all we're missing two people
uh Joe Sweeney and Bill hatch will see
them hopefully soon and we'll ask them
to introduce themselves a little bit I
appreciate all the good backgrounds and
especially all the experience on other
committees when we get done with the
budget I will talk about having Liaisons
to the other committees
and using your backgrounds I hope you
can volunteer for them and if you some
people don't want to do any so if you
want to do more than one that's fine
basically it is to deliver this message
we tend to be the bad guys
they work on a bill in in the policy
committee they think it's wonderful they
send it to us it needs a few million
dollars and we say no
and the message that I hope we can
deliver is
you know this agency better than any of
us
so
if they want to add two new employees or
three new employees for some new thing
look at the whole agency is there some
area they're not working as much as they
used to can they take three employees
and change them over to the three
employees that they're asking for makes
our job easier you get to complete the
bill we get to be happy that we didn't
have to raise new money we can find it
within the agency in most cases so if
it's a small amount we don't get really
upset but the idea is we don't want to
be the bad guys we want you to think
about the spending within that agency as
well as
the the things that go on in that agency
so now I get the opportunity to
introduce the Geniuses that keep this
all going and uh Michael Kane is the
legislative budget assistant has been
doing it for many years his abled
assistant is Chris true and I'll leave
it to him to introduce everybody and
give a little rundown Mr Kane sure thank
you
um
chairman Weiler members of the committee
um I'll give a quick introduction of our
staff you'll be able to meet them and
learn a little bit more about them after
lunch when they go into the division for
the orientation but uh just quick myself
my name's Michael Kane I'm the
legislative budget assistants I've been
working with the office of the LBA for
since 1999 so this is my beginning my
24th year next to me is Chris Shea he's
the deputy LBA he's also been working
with the LBA in both performance out of
capacity as well as the budget division
for
close to 27 years Chris is it 27 years
that was a great guess on my part and
then behind me here I have Mike Hoffman
the senior budget officer who has been
working with state government over 30
years
both Mike and I started within two weeks
every within a week of each other back
in 1999 with the LBA Mike has extensive
experience with both the legislative
branch and the executive branch next to
Mike is a new face for the finance
committee but not a new face for the
legislature Melissa Rollins used to work
with Department of Revenue
Administration so the members who have
been on Waze means have probably heard
presentation Melissa has 19 plus years
of experience with dra before we're able
to get her to come over here with
retirement of Nancy the Venus who some
of you may remember we lucked upon
Melissa looking for a new opportunity
she graciously accepted our offer and
we're a pleasure to have her
then the back row it's a little
different story but it's you know we
have Mickey landrigan and Mick landergan
who is also a senior budget officer Mick
has been with probably about 15 years
between audit and budget uh been with
our office for coming on eight years I
believe and uh Kevin Ripple Mickey
actually he'll deal with division two
Mike and Melissa with division one Kevin
Ripple behind us on same face still
Kevin he's going to be working with
division three he's been with our office
for uh 15 years as well between
performance audit and the budget
division working with the budget
division seven plus years so I'm very
grateful I get to work with these people
they're my friends and family back over
in the office it makes it easy coming
into work
and also it makes it a lot easier for us
to work with you and work with the
legislature so
um if I could leave it at that I'll go
right into the orientation I'm glad that
you mentioned a division and the
performance audits those products are
some of the most worthwhile if you're
studying an agency it may have been
three four five years ago that they did
an audit especially if it were a
performance audit so if you want to know
something about that agency get a hold
of an audit and read it and it have some
a lot of good information about what's
going on in that in that department so I
really like the output of the audit
thank you very much and I'll move into
the orientation and quickly mention the
LBA is a non-partisan office we do have
about 30 staff split between our budget
division which are the people you see
here including Pam Ellis who is
basically running the operation back
over in the State House releasing fiscal
notes fiscal impact statements and
everything else we ask of our so it's
we're very grateful to have Pam working
with us as well our audit division we
have both performance audits as
representative Weiler had mentioned uh
which are do perform on it's based on
direction from the legislative
performance audit oversight committee
and we also do our financial audits
split evenly right now between 12 and 12
between the two who perform your annual
Financial reports including the kafir or
the act for the annual comprehensive
financial report that was just released
at the end of December
so before you you have a 104 page
document which I am not going to go over
line by line or Page by Page more of a
reference document we put together if
you do have some questions it is online
if you do leave here and have some
questions on some of the things we go
over or maybe some of the rsas that may
drive some of the activity uh feel free
to use this document as well as the one
online
just quickly on page one of the document
is just the staff listing I've
introduced you to everyone here today
along with the numbers where you can
reach them as well as your email
addresses and my staff has great at
returning both voicemail and email so
feel free to get in touch with them at
as far as we do have a section on common
terms to find what's an appropriation
what is a class line we'll get into that
a little more once we get the budget
from the governor but basically right
now we're in the end of the fiscal year
22 or sorry the biennial 22 and 23
budget
um we're in the phase of Governor's
phase of developing the 24 fiscal year
24 and 25 operating budget so as you
know the legislature develops the budget
almost 18 months before the fiscal year
before the fiscal year ends so there's a
lot of estimates there's a lot of
um predictions and guesses that may or
may not come true it is a biennial
budget not all states as you know have
biennial budgets a lot of them do this
every year
um I came from Massachusetts where they
did a budget every year and probably
never finished on time once so for New
Hampshire to develop a budget two years
out and not open it up and when I say
open it up amend the budget many times
is a great um
it's a great effort by this Committee in
the Senate finance committee to put a
budget together for the next two years
we have a couple uh just going over into
rsa9 rsa9 or the statute that drives uh
the budget and it drives the uh what's
included uh as well as timelines
representative Weiler had mentioned the
governor on February 15th uh
required by Statute under RSA on page
four under rsa92 is transmit to the
legislature a budget
and this budget will be released on
February 15th the governor will provide
a and
give a presentation to the full
legislature on that date or right around
that date and then submit to him hit
what the governor believes the state
should do for the next two years that is
one person's opinion he does work with
the agencies as he develops his budget
to kind of put forward What policies and
what funding levels he would like to see
over the next two years
uh
page five is was added in 2019 but page
five is uh nine or say nine two a
transmission to the legislature changes
to statutory law and this is a reference
to uh what chairman Weiler mentioned the
trailer bill so the budget itself is a
large document uh
probably when the governor's budget
comes out it'll be over 1200 pages of
information with line items uh the
Appropriations by the class the class
being the uh what's in personnel and the
various other
um
components of of a budget but really a
technical document not very user or
reader friendly
what the legislature usually wait for
what the public also likes to see uh
what is what are the changes to be made
in the trailer build a trailer bill is
slowly becoming the size of household
one because there are many policy
changes statutory changes that are put
into the trailer Bill the reason for
that is because the Constitution does
not allow the budget Bill itself to
include changes to statutory law it can
only deal with the budget the
Appropriations themselves you'll see
things called footnotes which might
provide additional direction to the
Appropriations contained in the bill but
none of them changed statutory law if
anything comes overs or is you know even
from the governor is introduced or maybe
from an agency we make sure that any
statutory changes or any legal Law
changes are put into the trail will be
able to remain in compliance with the
Constitutional requirement
I'm going to skim over a couple of these
rsas and really just jump to um
a few on page 11.
you'll hear the question is there a
constitutional requirement to balance
the budget for New Hampshire the
balanced budget and technically no but
there is a statutory requirement under
RSA 98b the adoption of the operating
budget in summary that the estimated
revenues should be sufficient to fund
the estimated or the recommended
Appropriations for the budget and the
last sentence uh in on RSA 98b is one
that you'll hear or be discussed
throughout the whole process nothing
contained here in shall prohibit the use
of projected lapses in determining
compliance with the section
very quickly a lapse is basically an
unspent appropriation as I stated
previously the budget is developed
almost uh
two years in advance before the final
fiscal year
obviously there's a lot of estimates on
Personnel there's a lot of changes in
Personnel people come and go retire
leave
we also have estimates on maybe Medicaid
case loads or other caseload information
that the you know over the next several
months will change and as a result that
does leave some unspent Appropriations
so historically when I'll get to a
surplus statement a little later in this
document but when the balance budget is
proposed by the governor you'll see a
line on there which is a lapse what's
the lapse amount and basically it will
be an amount that the governor assumes
based on historic lapse figures or what
he knows he's put into the budget
what may not be spent by the end of the
year and the reason that lapse is there
it does give the current sitting
legislature and Governor the ability to
direct where that lapse goes absent
budgeted at a lapse if the lapse wasn't
budgeted and just occurred naturally
that would be additional funds that
would sit up there for the legislature
to make a determination at a ladder
point to either go into the rainy day
fund or to be used for another purpose
when you're developing a budget for two
years that lapse does give the
legislature some flexibility to maybe
directing that to where your priorities
are when you pass the budget but that
will be discussed we'll be interested to
see what the governor comes out in the
next month what he comes out with the
lapse estimates but historically it's
been about 60 to 80 million dollars a
year of a general fund lapse and we're
talking about you know 3.6 3.7 billion
dollars in general funds a year so not a
large amount it's usually lower than to
three percent but it is an amount a
chunk of change that the this current
sitting legislature can decide what they
want to do if it happens
and that is a just to kind of further on
the laps that's just an estimate it's
not a statutory required amount to hit
it is uh needed necessary in order to
balance the budget and the executive
branch takes the full responsibility for
ensuring that the state hits that lapse
amount to ensure there's a balanced
budget as is there um
that's basically that's their duty to
make sure that it does end in the
balanced budget Mr chairman may ask a
question
yes question yes thank you Mr chair
um have we ever gone back and looked at
the last five budgets or something to
see have how close the lapse estimates
have been to what the actual lapse was
two years later
yes and we do have I can put uh share
that history with the committee but we
do have a history of what the estimates
were in the past it was I'd say within
the last previous to five years ago we'd
usually be pretty close you'd be getting
pretty close to that lapse Mountain
that's it beginning in uh fiscal year 19
maybe we've been exceeding that lapse by
you know sometimes a hundred percent
where you'd have a hundred million
dollar lapse in one year when you
estimated 50 million a lot of that
having to do with the vacancies there's
a high vacancy rate state employees uh
they're slow filling those vacancies as
well as other Trends going down
um in other areas of the budget uh two
years ago we exceeded the lapse by
almost 100 million dollars uh this past
year we exceeded this past year that
just closed fiscal year 22 it was
assumed 64 million dollar lapse we came
in at 104 million so over 40 million
dollars and so yes as the uh house
finance committee develops that that is
information that we will share
information that you will go over and
talk with your agencies talk with the
governor and as budget director on why
they came up with the laps that they
came up with when historically we've
been hitting these certain amounts so we
okay
so if I were to go to page 14 is another
RSA 913e the revenue stabilization
Reserve account otherwise known as the
rainy day fund
so at the end of each biennium so at the
end of each odd number year any surplus
remaining in the journal fund is
deposited into the rainy day fund unless
otherwise directed by the legislature
that is something that you're going to
discuss uh with the budget that comes
out from the governor wouldn't want the
House and Senate propose over the next
few months by Statute that rainy day
fund
cannot exceed two years of general fund
unrestricted revenues plus any amount
that has gone into the rainy day fund
from settlements uh from the EG gets
settlements the big Exxon Mobil
settlement a while ago the Monsanto
settlement that came through 10 of those
large settlement amounts go into the
rainy day fund so it's a 30 plus million
dollars in the rainy day fund just from
settlements but in total at no point in
time can the legislature right now based
on the current law that was just past
two years ago can exceed two years the
general fund under restricted revenues
ballpark because we're currently in the
last uh year of the biennium of 20 three
ballparks about 400 million dollars in
which we are not at now and I'll get
into where we are right now but the
other thing to consider in the rainy day
fund is it is a um it's going to be a
discussion that the leadership has in
both the house and the Senate and the
governor have and where they're
comfortable
um with that rep where they're
comfortable with having a rainy day fund
balance it's not necessarily what
outside organizations may say is a good
uh buffer to have against a downturn
um it's what do you what do all of you
comfortable with because it is a you
know close to almost a half a billion
dollars if you hit the cap that is
either being collected in taxes that
aren't being used or it is not being
used for other services and based on the
emails you're probably receiving already
you know there's a lot of requests out
there and ideas on on what's a
comfortable level so it really is a
discussion overall discussion if I were
to look back in the last couple years
that figure has been about 100 150
million dollars is it previous
legislatures have been happy so what
will happen is when you're developing
the budget for 24.25 if the revenues
continue to come in how are they're
coming in right now which is 200 million
dollars
over the actual Revenue plan
um there'll be a discussion in the
legislature over the next few months of
how much of that you want to go into the
rainy day fund and how much you want to
use for maybe one time uh areas one-time
projects which has happened and I do
just want to mention that although there
is
requirements about two-thirds to be used
money from the rainy day fund uh there
have been since I've been here
suspensions of this RSA 913e for the
last several
um
mostly every budget since I've been here
and what that allows is the uh the gov
the legislature and the governor to
determine how much they should put in
there based on what they're hearing uh
from everyone that you talk to during
the development of the budget
so
there are a couple other transfer
Provisions that are relative to the
fiscal committee as we go through rsa9
and then a couple other
um
areas that we probably won't you know
you as a finance committee won't have to
deal with but we did want to put all of
our say 9 in there on page 22 is uh
these are the deadlines for the 2023
session
um and as representative Wilder
mentioned six weeks for the house to
develop a budget that's compared to the
Senate who has basically the month of
April in May to develop their budget
um so the house the task of the house
finance committee is a large task
um a very complicated Cask in a tight
time frame six weeks sounds like a long
time but considering we're already on
January 18th we're waiting for the
Governor's budget to be released on
February 15th the turnaround is going to
be almost about a month as you start to
make all your decisions to start
drafting your changes to House Bill 2 to
start at getting that information back
from the agencies to make the decisions
you want to make relative to The house's
position on the budget so just the two I
would highlight is the Thursday March
30th being the last day to report all
remaining house bills that would include
the budget under these deadlines and
what that means is that earlier in that
week that's a third Thursday early in
that week Monday and Tuesday's divisions
will be presenting their recommendations
to the full committee so that the full
committee can vote on what division one
two and three are proposing and if we
back up the weekend prior that means
division is really will be wrapping up
their work right around March 23rd March
24th in order to allow time to put the
documents together to present to the
full finance committee for their final
vote obviously deadlines can change but
right now these are the deadlines that
we're looking at
and if we turn over to page 23
um the Senate now the Senate will be
watching everything the house is doing
so as much as they're not going to
receive the document from the house
until the beginning of April they
usually do participate uh just by
watching not asking questions but by
watching what the divisions are doing
what are the divisions talking about
senates also having conversations with
the agencies conversations with the
governors during that time so by the
time they get the budget in
um April they have a pretty good idea
after the presentations by the finance
chairs of what's in the house budget
they also the Senate I would point out
the Senate has the benefit of
two huge Revenue months for the State of
New Hampshire March and April a big
Revenue collection months
what the house Ways and Means Committee
Chris works with the house Wheezy means
committee so over the next few weeks and
I think usually around the beginning of
March you'll get some idea of where the
house believes revenues will go the
difficulty in estimating revenues is
that March is such a large month for a
revenue collection that weighs and means
really has to use uh historical data in
individual meetings with agencies to
determine where they think revenues will
be those revenues will be communicated
with the chair of house finance with the
division shares with all the members and
that will be kind of the target for the
house finance committee to use when they
develop the budget when the Senate
receives the budget they wait they find
out what happens at the end of they'll
know what happened at the end of March
usually by the first week of April but
they wait to see how April will end
they'll have meetings with the agency
he's kind of bring them up to speed on
what they asked the governor and didn't
receive what they asked the house and
didn't receive or vice versa what they
did receive and maybe didn't request but
they'll use that month of April kind of
an information gathering and then once
the revenues come in at the end of April
on the first week in May they'll have a
better idea of where revenues will go
and they'll start to make a lot of their
large decisions uh in the month of May
usually prior to Memorial Day is when
the Senate has a good plan or where they
want to end up and again Senate very
open process as well so the house
finance committee members are watching
what the Senate is either asking us on
what the Senate's doing what the budget
and we're just keeping that
communication knowing in the end that
they'll have to be a resolution of any
differences between the house and the
Senate budget
that's what gets me to page 24 which is
a a kind of a chart of the operating
budget process and
um you know the tarp part usually works
pretty consistent with what you see here
but over the last few budgets I don't
think it's been as easy as submission to
the governor in passing uh there have
been some vetoes couple vetoes in the
past there have been instances where the
house uh had was unable to pass a budget
but then able to adopt a committee a
conference budget with continued
negotiations with the Senate during the
development to theirs but in general the
agency phase began almost a year ago the
agency phase being agencies start to
enter into the budget system the state
budget system uh the number of employees
where they think the current required
programs should be funded in the next
two years over the next from March
through October they're working to enter
that information into the system to
adjust based on any statutory change
that may be signed by the governor
passed by the legislature before that
time and then in October and October 1st
released the agency budget request which
are online uh significant documents we
did post them on our website it's easy
to find certain things with just a
control F on the document as opposed to
a box full of paper with those documents
which is very hard to find but basically
what you'll find in there is your your
efficiency budget which is what to
continue operations and meet the
statutory requirements right now
and also your additional prioritized
needs which is above and beyond what is
required by Statute at this point the
governor's phases right now and the
governor has until February 15th and
we'll use every minute working with the
agencies back and forth
try different things you know he the
governor's working on his estimates
right now with the various agencies the
area being the largest one and that's
also impacting his discussions he's
having with HHS that might have half a
billion dollars worth of requests for
other types of things that have been
requested remember they think they
should do as long as other agencies
um treasury you'll see in the agency
budget request almost 100 million
dollars roughly between the two years
and that really has to do with the
revenue sharing that's suspended every
uh two years but the governor is going
through all that and having discussions
with the agency so that on February 15th
they can present to you where he thinks
uh his recommended budget for the next
two years in addition to that typically
you receive the document the budget
document House Bill one on February 15th
OLS legislative services will receive on
February 15th the two years ago since it
is has only been two years since
required they'll receive the draft
document for House Bill 2. uh House Bill
2 being the trailer Bill and it usually
takes OLS about a week week and a half
sometimes two weeks depending on how
large to put that into Bill format now
you'll be meeting with the agencies in
the meantime asking them what is
in-house Bill to what is proposed by the
governor because all of that's going to
be kind of show its um
but basically introduce itself on the
governor's Surplus statement uh as well
as the agency budget so you'll have a
sense of what's in-house Bill too you
just won't see the actual wording until
usually the beginning right before the
beginning of March you'll get that
document
um and again this is something that
started off in one or two sections and
it's slowly over time morphed into a
larger document 300 plus sections for
various reasons one of the main reasons
is
yes it does start off pretty big from
the governor coming over but there's
almost a thousand pieces of legislation
that will go through the House and
Senate this year and we'll maybe stall
at one point it may have a cost in the
uh where you'll have it in finance
committee and decide to hold on uh
policy committee has recommended the
policy but you're going to see if it
fits into the budget and so you wait and
maybe you decide to put it at the house
bill too so that you have the funding
necessary to implement that policy
change that you want as as well as there
may be some bills that the house is
prioritized as this is a bit this is
priority of the house and if it stalls
in the Senate well maybe that's
something that the house wants to put
into House Bill 2 to keep a position
alive during a committee conference and
at least have that discussion with the
Senate when that comes the Senate does
the same thing they're watching their
Senate bills after crossover what goes
into the house what passes what's
amended and then maybe they work their
way if it has everything's related to
the budget so it can be anything really
um
but there is usually some Nexus with the
next two years and with the budget so
you'll see House Bill 2 over the uh
growing sometimes the largest parts of
House Bill 2 over half have to do with
either reorganization or combination of
statutes not the actual policy changes
or the two or three paragraphs but the
larger ones so
I think representative Edwards question
thank you Mr chair I you touched on this
a little bit but I've been trying to
figure this out
um uh lapsing versus non-lapsing if if
as we're approaching the end of the
two-year budget and there are monies
that you're projecting for lapses uh I
think I heard you say that those funds
could potentially be re-budgeted or
reprogrammed and spent in some in some
other way that I what what I've been
trying to recall is is the vehicle for
doing that because OLS is closed to us
so how do we deep into
[Music]
um our term uh submit any legislation
that would authorize spending elsewhere
yeah some of that will find its way
into house bill 2. so as you go through
this current fiscal year
um
you'll have until March at least through
the end of March
if the agencies are forthcoming which
what they think will elapse you could
put Appropriations from the current
fiscal year into House Bill 2 and that
you've seen that in the past a few of
the past budgets where you appropriate
current year projected surplus funds be
it from lapse of revenue for the current
year and that's how you address that
during a normal so during the 2022
session a lot of the there were a lot of
legislative specials 300 plus million
dollars of legislative specials
really based on the revenue Surplus
versus the lapse the lapse amount
compared to the revenue Surplus we have
has been small but it still plays into
that pot so either through House Bill 2
or a legislative especially in the
second year of the session is how any of
those additional dollars that haven't
already been uh authorized or
okay so
um legislative specials where where does
that come from where who gets to craft
that bill for a legislative special
any legislator
um you'll see legislative specials that
are introduced into the Senate
individually for instance
um seven and a half percent uh
contribution to Municipal Retirement and
22 was a 26 million dollar appropriation
so I'm just going to keep things going
so I'm just trying to make sure that OLS
actually supports those because because
sometimes they can be the the roadblock
to say no we're not doing any more work
for you yes so you might be past your
deadline to introduce new legislative uh
new legislation but a way not a way
around that but of a way in the process
is to amend a bill that might be before
you where you could put even though you
don't have a chance to introduce a new
bill you could add an amendment onto
another bill so one more follow-up
I I anecdotally think I have noticed a
trend towards asking that more and more
of the budget uh be converted over to
non-lapsing versus lapsing have you
picked up on a trend is that my
imagination or is that real
and and if it is real how significant is
it
um it is real uh it tends to happen in
division three
um in Health and Human Services more
than any because they do have some
caseload uh and eligibility entitlement
programs
um agencies may ask a lot for
non-lapsing but um
it's it's uh I would say they would
rather make sure they meet their lapse
estimate with any available funds as
opposed to putting a non-lapsing
component in the first year of the
budget the reason I say that if you had
an agency like administrative Services
who the governor said you have the lapse
five million dollars by the end of the
fiscal year they really bind themselves
if they make those funds non-lapsing
because they're going to have to look
somewhere else instead of using the
funds that would otherwise have lapsed
you do have HHS has an impact the lapse
too much because a majority of your
lapse is coming from your vacancies but
a lot of your non-lapsing funds debt
services on you do have some of your
Medicaid programs are non-lapsing until
the second year of the biennium
those are more
um
kind of cushions against unexpected
activity or performance or performance
against estimates for some of the
programs but it doesn't tend it I don't
see it as a trend in the larger scale
but maybe some of your larger
entitlement programs your 200 plus
million dollars to have that 10 or 12
million into the next year uh sometimes
really helpful for those agencies
thank you for that that was very good uh
I'm it's going to take me a couple of
walks around that to really understand
and I hope Mr Ripple keep training me on
yeah
so house patch uh Senate and then
committee conference uh part of the
budget is where house has its position
Senate has its position and then you
work out the differences within a small
crunched time frame of usually under a
week and you all come to an agreement
and then pass a budget over to the
governor who at the same time is still
communicating with the House and Senate
uh during the entire process on things
that maybe he sees that he he agrees
with or doesn't agree with but to keep
that those lines of communications open
and then the final the House and Senate
both have one final vote uh at least one
final vote of adopting that Committee of
conference report so it has to be
something not that the house finance
committees agree on but something that
you know you can bring back to your body
and have passed a second time
what happens if it doesn't pass well two
things the budget could be vetoed
um which it has been in the past
um what happens then is a continuing
resolution an option is to keep the
funding of the current government
um in this is based on a level that is
agreed to by the house senate and
Governor it doesn't have to be the
current year level it could be the
current year level plus the current year
level minus it's happened back in 2003
was the budget has passed by the
legislature there's a very short veto
period but that and what happens there
is you'll have like a three-month budget
agencies will be given the ability to
come into fiscal committee to accept uh
above and beyond that amount
um
so it makes fiscal's job a lot harder
during those three because at the same
time members of the fiscal committee are
also negotiating what the final budget
will be
um but there is a way to get through
that apps in a continuing resolution
um which hasn't happened knock on wood I
like to bring everything up is would
probably be a government shutdown if you
would have no agreement on a continuing
resolution since I've been here only
since 99 that has not occurred usually
over the three months of a cool down
period or further discussion period
between the house senate and legislature
summer agreement can come sometimes that
agreement has gone right to the end of
September sometimes it happens right
after Labor Day but never say never
um
so we just kind of keep track of that
and you know maybe 3 12 of a budget is
not good enough maybe you need another
week whatever it can be anything that
the governor and legislative leadership
want to put forward
um
and then we get into house bill one uh
on page 25. I didn't include all of
house bill one I just included kind of
the cover page so you see kind of what
that looks like uh the introduction
paragraph on page 26.
we have so-called we call them footnotes
which is on page 27 and 28 and these are
not statutory changes but more
restrictions put on some of the uh
transfer or use of certain
Appropriations uh maybe some limits uh
back of the budget cut and Personnel
would be included in here
um you know making sure that over time
and maintenance doesn't lapse so these
are all changes that are law but they're
not changing statutes so they are it is
appropriate to have them in hospital one
as sections but very small and at the
end of that on page 31 and 32 are your
base Revenue estimates
um here based on committee conference
but for you what you'll include in your
house bill one is your base Revenue
estimates from the house Wheezy Means
Committee for the general fund education
trust fund Highway and fishing game
and then just an example of what the
budget looks like on page 33
not a very reader friendly document not
a very easy document to find uh things
and it's a very detailed account it's an
accounting document that is transferred
over uh basically turn a key and the
legislature the executive branch starts
to spend out of those funds once that
budget has passed
but on the top I'll just go over kind of
quickly just the top
um
on the left hand side 0 2 is your
category so administrative it's Justice
and public protection so you'll have
category one through six one being
General government two being
administration of justice and public
protection three resource uh and
protection for transportation five
Health and Human Services and six
education you don't have to remember
that here uh the next two uh rows 20 is
an agency code so Justice is from the
counting in the accounting system is
agency 20. so any activity for the
Department of Justice any Appropriations
occurs under there and then you have
your um
this will see your activity
your activity is division of legal
council so 2010 10 is just another uh
just a figure
it's a set of numbers to keep track of
everything that occurs under that
activity being the division of legal
council so you might have multiple uh
levels but you can always sum up to that
Division and then 26 23 is a unique
number for transportation under
Department of Justice and we use that
that's called we call that the
accounting unit those all those one two
three four five digits your accounting
unit and that's how the state budgets
and that's how the state keeps track of
it after the budget and then down you'll
see the classes your zero 10 is your
Personnel Services 0-13 uh is your
unclassified Personnel Services and then
your class 60 060 your benefits there
are several classes our analysts as you
develop your budget will go over
multiple uh with you as you get to each
agency because there are some that are
unique to certain agencies but a lot
most of them majority of them are
budgeted under the same your class 10
across agencies are
permanent classified employees and
that's going to be the same for
Department of Justice or health and
human services and so that way you can
summarize how much you're spending on a
certain type of service by the class
level and then your source of funds down
low estimated source of funds this one
is a transfer from the Department of
Transportation so it's other funds show
up as other funds in the budget but
there's a sending account under the
Department of Transportation to fund
this this arm of the Department of
Justice so this is what you'll see this
is what you'll use when representative
Wilder mentioned you'll go through Page
by Page line by line of a budget when
the governor's budget comes out you'll
have an actual history so you'll have
your 22 actual expenditures for every
single accounting unit your 22 actual
expenditures your 23 adjusted authorized
which are your Appropriations plus any
other legislative or fiscal or GNC
activity that occurred prior to our
dates or usually August 15th and then
you can look at trends you can ask
questions on why do you have equipment
why has it gone up why is your personnel
increasing if you've only spent you know
X on this class line and 22 what has
changed over the last year to make your
request go up by 20 25 and it varies
from each agency so you'll notice those
when the um the agencies start coming in
presenting the governor's budget you'll
notice those big jumps
um and you can ask those questions when
you get there and feel free to ask our
analysts as well if you have any
questions ahead of time once you get the
governor's budget and we do our best we
learn with you when the governor's
budget because we really are not
involved right now with the governor
once it's released on February 15th we
do our best with you to kind of come up
to speed really quick so that the
legislature can start doing that
sure
question
thank you just a very quick question I
think I heard you say that those three
digit codes object codes or whatever you
want to call them are mostly consistent
around departments which seems to imply
that the same code could have different
meanings in different departments could
you clarify whether that's the case
sure there may be one or two and I say
there's um
your class tens through 80 are all
consistent across departments
um
there used to be now this is probably 10
years ago class 90 that could be
different across departments it could be
fish food versus uh purchase of copying
supplies in another over the past
several years the Department
administrative Services has worked to
have unique codes for each agencies
um so you're there should only be one or
two it's very rare now to have
um dueling class codes to have different
meetings because they do like develop a
specific but I can't tell you a hundred
percent that there's not one like 523
class that might be used across agencies
with a different description but we have
came a long way from back in 2003 with a
class 90. uh if you got a budget report
on class 90 it wouldn't tell you
anything because it could include
provider payments to Health and Human
Services it can include purchase
payments to UNH so it's been a lot
better since over the last 10 years
to maintain that consistency and that
accuracy and Reporting so thank you very
much and thank you Mr chairman
okay
and then on page sorry sorry
thank you
um what are class 40 and 42 these are
fairly large items
yep so
class 40 is your indirect cost so uh any
overhead costs to be chargeable back to
the treasury
um the state sets up this so-called
Statewide indirect cost allocation plan
known as the sway cap that is approved
by the U.S Department of Health and
Human Services that provides a rate of
what is an overhead cost that other
agencies
incur on their behalf administrative
services for any of the accounting
reports treasury for the checks so if
you're in other funded agency there is
an indirect cost that you're required to
pay now those funds go into the general
funders of the revenue
I'm blanking on how much that amount is
could be 10 to 12 million dollars a year
and basically that offsets any general
fund cost from those
other agencies
and then 42-year additional fringe
or non-journal funded agencies or
agencies who don't send administrative
Services specific funds retiree health
is uh
available to eligible employees based on
the years of service Department
administrative Services has the large
appropriation it's Journal funds but it
also includes money from a retirement
subsidy for limited amount of employees
but also sending agencies your fish and
game department of
transportation and safety send their
share of retiree Health based on your
current number of employees so it's kind
of a it's not a direct charge based on
what we're paying on behalf of your
employees but it's allocated to various
agencies based on the number of
employees that you have and the
percentage of your budget that is
non-general funding it's really to
offset that general fund cost for State
retiree health insurance
thank you it's going to take more than
once to sink in it yes it is when you
get to that line in in division one we
get to that line one of your largest
lines for retiree health during the
budget you'll start to see that agency
income and it'll make a little more
sense
back to
um where you did the budget footnotes on
page 27. right so the Constitution does
not or the Constitution prohibits
statutory changes
but can you waive a statute
right is that what happens in the
footnote section because you you
mentioned earlier right that there's a
two-thirds requirement for
managing the rainy day fund yet
typically is overridden by probably a
simple majority is that done in the
footnotes so you can't change the
statute but you can say ignore the
statute is that a good way to think
about it yes and that would happen in
your house bill too okay
um hospital when you see here if there
are any references to statute it should
be purely reference for the house bill
one sections but in House Bill 2 you can
um
either suspend a statute or the word the
term used is not withstand so basically
ignore as you stated a statute or
statute requirements if it is signed
into law correct
okay
and then on page 34 is a document that
you will see usually at the end of your
process to and this is a compared
document this is something we put online
so that state agencies and the public in
the legislature can keep track of
differences between the in this instance
the governor and the house budget so
when the house passes a budget where
were the changes made this is a document
that the Senate will use when they
develop their budget to see what changes
is made but also the house will refer to
we'll have a couple
um
compare documents put up what changes
the Senate made to the house or the
Senate made to the governor and so we'll
keep those documents on our website
these are large documents usually 15
1600 page documents but they do have
great detail on you know a 4 800 change
uh in Hardware software just to kind of
keep track of everything that was
changed
and quickly on page 35 is the State
Constitution Article 18a which does
specific does state that and I'm going
to paraphrase that no section or
footnote of any such budget Bill shall
contain any provision which establishes
amends a repeal statutory law I would we
do tend to anything that ignores or not
withstands we do like to put in House
Bill 2 as well just to keep with them to
make sure that everything is in
compliance with the Constitution
and then House Bill 2 we just we didn't
print the entire house bill 2 which was
300 plus sections but we did provide you
with on page 36
um through
43 44
just uh what is included uh you'll have
our judicial branch
reimbursement for cost of court security
you'll have a consolidate human resource
and payroll functions which I think you
have seen for every budget for the last
10 years
um extending appropriation dates making
Appropriations to certain
funds reducing tax rates for the meals
and rooms tax making any changes to tax
law that make it into house bill too
legislature has a choice you either pass
a separate bill with any tax changes
usually every appropriation Bill comes
to finance but for tax changes you can
either let that pass on its own and will
account for any impact on our Surplus
statement which I'll get to or you can
include that in-house Bill too if it's
something both the House and Senate
degree usually let that bill pass but if
it's something you are having to Bates
with the housing center on what's
appropriate you will have may put that
into house bill too just to solidify
your position and fund your side
and then on page 45 is a small when you
receive these during the process
um they'll be on legal size they'll this
is the Surplus statement so this is a
combined General and education trust
fund Surplus statement this is a
document internal document we use
um to make sure that the legislature
recommends a balanced budget again this
is you know for this one on page 45 and
this was developed on June of 21 for the
next two years so it's based on your
Revenue estimates any Revenue
adjustments which are any changes to
taxes any changes in Appropriations that
may impact revenues if you had an agency
that is provides its net profit to the
general fund and and you increase their
funding but it doesn't increase their
revenue that could be a negative
adjustment the ra sometimes they receive
additional positions that could bring in
additional Revenue auditor positions so
you may have a positive adjustment so
that's where we keep track of Revenue
adjustments and then we have our budget
Appropriations
which are your hospital one
Appropriations just from the total page
in the back and then your appropriation
adjustments these could be individual
Appropriations for certain purposes for
one year for two years that are outside
the your standard operating budget they
could be one-time funding provided in
the either current fiscal year or the
next two fiscal years or again an impact
from legislation that may have passed
the legislature that could have an
impact on Appropriations going forward
education for instance if you had a big
policy bill go through education that
changed your adequacy formula and it
passed the policy committees and went
over to the Senate vice versa passed we
would make sure that although it didn't
come to finance we want to make sure
that you account for it on your balance
sheet and so this is the best we do up
to that point
and then you'll see on page 46 six you
do the same thing for Highway funds so
division two you'll be working with
Mickey
for the highway fund
both the revenues that are coming in
based on estimates from Ways and Means
and then working with those agencies
that use Highway funds which are
Department of Transportation as well as
Department of Safety and there are a
couple smaller hits from other agencies
but majority of those two and then on
the next page of Fish and Game fund on
page 47 based on Revenue estimates from
Ways and Means proposed budgets and then
any changes made you'll see here on page
47 there was a change to Department of
Information Technology Appropriations
and since doit as it's known uh the
division one will talk about they spread
some other costs out to all the agencies
you will see impact on some of these
other balance sheets for your
non-journal fund agencies and so you'll
see there as well as the cost of a pay
raise it was a pay raise that passed in
House Bill two two years ago and you'll
see that there's a fishing game and a
highway fund portion of that as well as
a education as well as a general fund
on page 48 our pie charts representative
Weiler these aren't all the pie charts
we've done I've just included a couple
pie charts just a visualization of uh
number one not only the size of the
budget
but this more or less what each category
that I briefly mentioned before there's
six categories the total budget all
funds was about thirteen and a half
million dollars for the current biennium
for 22.23 HHS makes up about
43.4 or Category 5 43.4 percent of that
pie so you see the largest pie being
under category five which is all
division three yes question
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair
um does this uh chart correlate neatly
to what division one and division two do
I I know I can guess which one is
division three but are are these other
five
directly and completely correlated to
another division
no no
um so I can tell you category five is
absolutely division three division two
kind of touches Upon A Little Bit of
Everything apps all of category six uh
division two takes all of category
um so can I restate my question
because I'm so concerned about the new
members of Finance can we get a listing
of which division as what part of the
budget
I'm gonna pretend for now I already know
it and I just want everyone else to know
it so if we can put it in writing
somewhere we can do that in the division
briefings yeah I think our some of our
analysts will have that handout for you
but I cannot what it can also do is do a
um a pie chart by division if that's
helpful just so you can see I wouldn't
ask for that it doesn't take that long
thank you very much just quickly to
continue on what you were talking about
with regards to the division breakdowns
I had a conversation with the speaker's
office actually about including those on
the House website when you click on the
Committees uh each committee yes it
breaks down into membership but really
each committee should break down in a
very detailed description and even
further down each division should have
the categories you're talking about
right there on the House website thank
you okay sure and we can uh work with uh
Journal core technology services to give
them that information so that they can
put that in the drop down for division
one
um division one basically the high level
you're it's your general government
under category one it's uh your category
two other than the department of safety
because they're funded from Highway
funds and it's uh your category three
except fish and games since they're
funded with fish and game uh division
two being your category four for
transportation your category six for
education and then safety and fishing
game but we do have a listing of that
on page
49 is just a high level uh bar chart
relative to the source of funding so yes
13 and a half billion dollar budget
um but
um you know where does that come from
well we can see the Top Line federal
funds make up a majority uh they make up
4.2 million dollars when I say majority
they're the highest share uh the largest
percentage share uh 4.2 billion dollars
general fund coming next at 3.3 other
funds are all your different agency
income but the largest one there almost
two billion dollars of it is your
education trust fund is another fund uh
I'm sorry not anymore the other fund is
your insurance your banking your agency
income lines your transfers amongst the
various agencies education fund at two
billion dollars has been broken out in
the orange Highway about 490 million
Turnpike 336 and then liquor fishing
game Etc
so
uh doit being one of your largest other
funded agencies because they do receive
funding from every single agencies that
use their services and then on page 50
uh the LBA statute of the fiscal
committee statute there's a fiscal
committee that is responsible for
overseeing the budget when it passes
overseeing the additional funds that
come through outside of the budget
process maybe some one-time funds or
funds that aren't guaranteed for the
next two years
fiscal committee does have that
requirement to accept and expend allow
accept an expenditure of those funds
allow transfer of any budgeted funds you
have in certain classes unless there's
limitations or restrictions fiscal
committee will be the legislative the
five members of the Senate five members
of the house that will oversee any
changes to the budget as well as any
funds that come in after they're also
responsible for appointing us and then
sorry you have a question question
representative emmerich
thank you Mr chair uh I think it was at
this point
in this in the briefing in previous
times when we talked about double
accounting
yep and the and I just wanted to ask the
question again doit out charges itself
to everybody
but its budget is also part of this
budget yes yes so the Departments are
paying for it and doit is paying for it
so in essence
whatever doit's budget is
for them it's also found throughout all
the other agencies I just wanted to Sure
yes and if we go back to page 49 a
majority of your other funds are the
so-called um not a majority but a large
share of your other funds are so-called
double counting and I say double
counting because in our how the budget
is set up is that an agency may have
let's say Department of Transportation
for instance has a project that toit is
working on for them or just their normal
support of um for web development for
any other software
doit will charge
um
Department of Transportation for those
costs that are related to them
so what happens is you have your
spending account so you have your
Department of Transportation meet the
actual expenditure
transferring over to doit and then doit
showing the expenditure in their budget
like is it under their General
Administration is under a specific so
you have both the receiving agency and
the sending agency spending being double
counted what is in the budget if we look
to an old house bill one if you look on
the last under
um it's in the totals but it's also
under each agency there's been a removal
of the double counting at least visually
so you can see of every agency how much
of that is double count it's usually a
couple hundred uh to 300 million dollars
each fiscal year and to give a real
budget total of what the state is
actually appropriating so that you don't
um you know you don't say you've
appropriated 13
0.8 billion when you were only really
appropriated 13.5 because the you know
300 million is double counting so that
is a new development uh or new change in
the budget Bill itself that was
implemented probably
two budgets ago that makes it a little
more clear because the double counting
is an issue when you start to look at um
start to compare budgets
follow-up so uh thank you the so the
13.54 million or billion is net
it should be I will I'll verify that it
should be negative double counting yep
yeah thank you sure at least from that
side now you'll have Duit show up as
other funds but you won't uh the Double
counting out of the sending agency won't
and then fiscal committee
um on page 50 they're also responsible
for uh overseeing our office appointing
the LBA uh over seeing the work of our
staff but also with the various
transfers and accepting expenditure of
funds and then I'll usually during the
budget that's one part of it but fiscal
committee historically had approved
between two and three hundred million
dollars a year of other funds mostly
federal funds that come in it might be
one-time uh funding that's not an
ongoing or maybe the legislature has
asked them to come into the fiscal
committee to give fiscal committee
another chance of the legislature
another chance to discuss these various
programs but what you'll see on the next
several pages is not only what fiscal uh
historically approves but
the increase of the additional fiscal
approvals as a result that resulted from
cares and arpa funds so almost 1.6
billion dollars in funds coming in
through fiscal which is not your
standard run-of-the-mill fiscal items
rarely it has not been that high it has
been two to three hundred million with
most of it coming from your HHS or maybe
some environmental services State
revolving loan funds but with arpa I
think you can see I think I highlighted
a couple of the totals
um
on page 65 we know that in 22
a total of 1.5 billion dollars of
federal funds came in through fiscal for
22.
um and then in 23 that amount
um
being already in the
651 million dollars
of additional federal funds and that's
on page 72 so almost 2 billion dollars
have come in through fiscal and that is
not that is only because of your arpa
funds your 1.25 billion in the first uh
of our cares funds received and another
billion dollars that was received under
that program as well as all the
individual Federal Acts that have passed
after passage to the budget or
um
are not going to be ongoing operating
budget expenses since they do the
authority to use these funds does run
out also on that fiscal committee uh
reporting uh you will see a column
called General funds and so there are
instances where the fiscal committee is
given specific Authority by the
legislature to appropriate General funds
not for every agency but for specific
agencies judicial Council for Indigent
defense department of justice for
litigation expenditures those will be
two issues that division one will be
talking about because historically those
are agencies that come back and ask
fiscal for additional General funds they
do have the discussion during the budget
process whether or not to budget those
funds in the operating budget but
historically what the legislature has
decided to do is to have them come back
to fiscal committee if they need it
um
Department of Justice for instance it
gives the fiscal committee
a little more oversight into
expenditures for outside attorneys or
any other litigation expenses as opposed
to a block appropriation in the budget
but it's really up to the legislature
what they're comfortable with and then
there are a couple other small instances
where agencies can come in and ask for
additional General funds in the events
or emergencies or shortfalls but not
every agency has that opportunity only
uh
only when fiscal is given that exclusive
That explicit Authority from the full
legislature
just to clear up that um
and then if I were to go all the way
through the end of that document and to
page 87 and I won't take up too much
your time but the annual comprehensive
financial report will be presented to
the fiscal committee on their first
meeting which is next uh week from this
Friday so the 27th
annual comprehensive reporters the
so-called Aquarius to be referred to as
the Capper but in this this is basically
six months after the close of the fiscal
year
the state must have an audited financial
report of all their expenditures and
revenues and activity for that fiscal
year
this the cappers this was what actually
happened and this is not going to change
um I say that because the committee of
conference documents and legislative
documents on the Surplus statements are
purely estimates but the Catherine for
any who is audited final and where we
ended up so on page 88 for instance
this will give you uh it's kind of a
summary of a general education trust
fund on a surplus statement type
presentation but it will show kind of
where you were where you ended up in 22
um for revenues for instance uh revenues
total editions almost 3.2 billion
dollars that was almost 400 million
dollars over legislative estimates back
in 21.
um and then you have Appropriations uh
will you see a lapse line you can see
the 104.8 million dollars under the
deductions 104 was actually lapsed when
the committee conference had estimated
about 64. so about a 40 million dollar
difference additional Appropriations or
things that pass by when the budget
passes in 21 or when it passes in 23
there may be uh individual legislation
that passes that appropriates money
outside of that process so those would
be accounted for as well and then any
chances to the rainy day fund Highway
fund transfers are directed by my house
bill 2 that's why there's 50 million
dollars that has gone in but the
undesignated fund balance
um was
361.3 million dollars
now that is the ending balance in 22 22
being the first year of a biennium that
would automatically carry over no
deposit is made into the rainy day fund
until the last year the biennium so the
odd numbered year so that 361
and that compares to during the
from not mistaken
um
67.4 was where we thought 22 would end
based on the revenues and appropriation
it's almost a 300 million dollar swing
majority of that with Revenue
um so it's it's you're gonna see
um when the governor releases his budget
for 23 the fiscal year we're currently
in that's going to vary from what the
committee conference uh assumed back in
21 uh large largely because through
December 200 the state is 200 million
dollars up in Revenue now again March
and April could change that but
um we're in a positive variance we
started with a much larger balance board
as a result based on the economic
briefing which I think is online that I
had given a quick snapshot of where we
are beginning 23 which I'll present
again to house finance once the
governor's budget is released but there
was almost a you know a surplus of
183 million in the general fund right
now just based on where our revenues are
to date obviously that can change
there'll be items that come to fiscal
Community to spend additional General
funds there'll be additional Revenue
changes that occur but the legislature
knowing that Revenue in 22 did decide to
appropriate almost 300 million of uh
one-time funding for various various
projects so
they can't figure in a good position
159.9 million dollar in that rainy day
uh fund
um and that doesn't include 100 million
dollars that was set aside for the uh
the YDC settlement so the sununu center
a hundred million dollar the legislature
722 to move that out of the rainy day
fund and set it aside for the YDC
settlement so still shows on our books
but it's dedicated for that purpose so
the state is in a great financial
position as we sit here today but as
with any budget any estimates we have no
idea what's going to happen over the
next two or three years so but right now
you're in a great position and as far as
history
um
Pages 18 I'm sorry did representative
Edwards have a question sure question
representative Edwards
so so just to help us Define a great
financial position
um we have external Bond agencies that
have rated the state I understand we're
a b-plus state or are we something else
uh higher I thought we were double a uh
depending on the rating agency yeah okay
so we're we're in a double a status now
in general yeah we're not the top but
we're not uh we are we have a very good
Bond rating which is not at the top it
just feels like it's gotten higher since
I was on Ways and Means and and so uh
yep okay yeah I can look it is great I
just wanted to know what great Matt okay
oh so great I guess it's all relative
right so at General and education Trust
on your grade if people start
questioning you on your retirement
system liability or uh yeah they might
not say so great but as far as your
current cash balance for Budget purposes
and journal you're in a great shape so
and then as far as uh history
um
just kind of the Capper has a great
tables this is uh it's on page 148 the
cat for 89 of the handout we put in a
few of these historic your schedule of
unrestricted Revenue uh for the general
fund for the last 10 years so you can
see uh significant pretty good growth in
general fund revenue is a 1.4 million
dollar billion dollars in 2013 up to 1.9
and that is after any tax changes that
were made so the almost two billion
dollars in taxes
uh page 90 being your education trust
fund you can see 10-year history back in
2013 through 2017 the education trust
fund was in a um the education trust
fund is a fund and Mickey will go over
it at some point in division two but
it's basically uh it's a non-lapsing
fund and if in the event that there are
not sufficient funds the education trust
fund the general fund has to kick in
you'll see 2013 through 2017 based on
the revenues and the expenditures coming
out of the education trust so the
general fund had to contribute and that
was like that if you look at the
previous five years same way but over
the last several years you'll see that
there's no transfers were required from
2019 through 2022 into the education
trust fund because the revenue going
into that fund uh largest being
Statewide education property tax and
business taxes were sufficient to fund
adequate education or your education
Freedom accounts and anything else
that's a charge against that fund and
that's something the division two will
dive into and ensure that there's a
balance or at least see education trust
fund is in a good position at the close
of the budget Mickey landergan will be
the one to basically keep um
keep track of that so page 91 is
education trust fund specific what I
showed you before was the general fund
um on page 92 is your Highway fund and
I'll usually we'll I'll fly right over
the highway fund but you can see in 2013
a 46.3 million dollar balance in the
highway fund
um your additions your Revenue into the
highway fund were about 285 million in
2013. there are 281 million in 2022 so
over 10 years have actually declined but
the balance in the highway fund is
111.6 million dollars that does include
50 million dollars that the general fund
had deposited into the highway fund last
budget process so absent that you'd be
in above the 51 million dollar balance
but it does exist and it does currently
sit uh fishing game is on page 93 again
just a kind of a 10-year history your
additions your revenues have increased
from 11.5 in 2013 to about 14.9 uh the
balance of the fund as low as 1.6
million actually dropped down to 401
thousand dollars in 2015 in the fish and
game fund but right now uh because of
the increases in revenues as well as
additional general fund Support over the
last few budgets here at about 9.8
million dollars in the fish and game
fund and you're you're talking about a
fund with revenues or expenditures right
around the 11 million so 9 million
dollars is a pretty healthy balance in
that fund
and then page 94 I'll just go through
this quickly this is uh your schedule of
state employees by function for the last
10 fiscal years so this is what the
kafir reports so you can see the numbers
of state employees these are both your
part-time your state full-time employees
as well as your part-time and temporary
employees and this is something that
each division will go through with each
agency you're going to look at their
Staffing accounts you're going to look
at there you're going to talk about
their vacancy rates this will be one of
the it's usually a large discussion or a
big discussion in the house when you
develop their budget because you're
looking historically over what they've
been appropriated what they've been able
to fill and Etc so
further question
okay as you as we came out of uh page 93
uh we we had just uh summarized some of
the statutory fund balances and and so
now I have a trivia question that you
may not know the answer to uh the uh the
prescription drug affordability board as
uh as it exists in current statute
um
it has the ability to set its own fees
and I think it's also set up to be
non-lapsing and the ability to collect
125 percent of their budget and stuff
are are they gonna are they going to be
do you know now how we're going to
review that board are they going to have
their own fund balance sheet that we
that we look at or or
do you want to talk about that offline
or I a sure yeah so so high level
there'll be a the agency budget request
I believe had a budget request for
prescription drug affordability board
I'm sure the governors going over it now
and how he'll present the budget if it's
a dedicated fund specifically for that
board they will be able to provide you
maybe not down to this oh yeah your
additions and your subtractions from
that fund and give you kind of a status
of where they see there now or where
they think they'll be based on estimated
revenues so you could ask them for that
absolutely
ask them for that or or or the LBA will
routinely provide it as in the same
format as any other fund balance is it
going to be different or the same uh
it's such it's a small amount so we
wouldn't do a separate Surplus statement
for each dedicated fund so I would ask
them specifically uh for that we could
prepare it with them for you but there's
over 300 you know there's hundreds of
dedicated funds so
um for this the dedicated funding report
would have it after the fact but as you
develop the budget it's probably
something you want to ask us for and
we'll help with that together
sure and just a reminder there are
several agencies that are somewhat
supported by fees Insurance Banking and
this one you just referred to with with
medic
um prescription drugs so the idea is
that it it keeps it even so as as new
banks are added a new insurance
companies are added they are able to to
adjust the fees and that agency is
expected to provide 125 percent of their
costs because the cost usually only
reflect the
the salaries and the in the heat and
light for the office and so on but
there's also kind of an unknown cost
which is the retirement system so that's
why the extra 25 goes in there to ensure
that they don't come to us later and say
oh by the way we're short on retirement
contributions or fringe benefits or
something like that so there's some
debate over whether that's the right
thing to do some people feel there's too
much influence by the bank so by the
insurance company there's too much
coziness of the people that they're
doing business with and being audited by
that they are also paying them directly
so
there's somebody we used to have
something similar with labor
and we switched it over to General funds
well they they were producing enough
funds in fines and and fees to cover
their expenses it was around a million
something on that agency but people said
oh no this is too cozy and everything so
that there's an example of us switching
taking their money that they brought in
putting it in the general fund and then
paying them out object of the general
fund what was needed so
those are some things we've done in the
past and we could still consider in the
future thank you sure representative
American looks like he has a question
representative memory thank you uh I'm
looking at the at the growth of these uh
restricted fund balances and it looks to
me like a lot of these agencies are
developing their own rainy day fund
uh because that's what it appears
because it's like what what happens with
this when this sounds like it's cash
sitting there uh but kind of how does it
get out allocated to be spent
a fiscal committee so uh fish and game
for instance if if they want to
um
it's basically called The Fish game
Surplus account so it's basically
anything that's not budgeted they can
come to fiscal and ask for those funds
be it for overtime sometimes for patrols
sometimes for equipment Highway fund
there's Surplus what fiscal usually see
is probably soon probably in your
February March they'll come in for
winter maintenance depending on they'll
use the highway Surplus account but they
do need fiscal committee and genes the
government Council of approval before
spending that so a little more flexible
than like a rainy day account since they
do just need fiscal committee approval
to tap into it but they do also have the
oversightful legislature when they come
back in to make sure that they're not
constantly doing that highway I would
say and you'll talk about in division
two the unrestricted Revenue in the
highway fund as a result of the road to
so-called gas tax it's pretty steady you
know as cars become more efficient and
so
um
you know that's why the general fund had
jumped in in the past and uh provided
more funding for them but you can see
that they're at a very 111 million uh
even with the 50 million deposits so
they do like to have some type of
cushion I don't want to speak for them
now but typically even the legislature
wants to see the highway in the fish and
game fund with some cushion but what
level you're comfortable with is
definitely up to you
we may get something passed in this
session
for all the vehicles that don't pay much
into the highway fund because they're
Electric
more their margin they're you know
hybrid fuels or something so the the
biggest thing that goes into the highway
fund is the gas tax
which is called the toll and it's uh
that's why we've had to put more money
into them in the last several years
because the gas tax wasn't bringing in
enough everybody was getting better
mileage
and now we're going to these electric
cars and they're going down the road
with a thousand pounds
of battery versus 80 pounds of gasoline
it's a lot more wear and tear on the
roads and they're not paying anything so
we've argued about that but we've got to
try to find some Solution on that this
next term hopefully Transportation
committee will find something and
we'll be involved thank you sure
um and then just the next few pages if I
take you to page 95 this is really just
a summary of your agency budget request
uh the first few pages are all funds
that's total funds and then you have
your general funds uh just based on time
it basically have your actual and your
adjusted authorized for the current
biennium your efficiency budget which is
set out in statute which should be
included or not your additional
prioritized needs which is the lack of a
better term your wish list or your
suspension's statute that require
um you know changes so you can see and
then your total agency request
these numbers will change dramatically
your 20 uh 425 when the governor's
budget comes out by agency because right
now he is going detail uh to the level
of the house usually to come up with
what he believes should be provided so
what is the source of these the agency
request in November yes yes the ANC
budget request correct this is uh the
source of this document the agency
better request that released uh that the
governor had budget hearings back in
November on those
um and then just the last few pages 100
to 104s
and your analysts will uh we'll talk
about it with your divisions just on
kind of how we can help you through this
process there's a lot of numbers there's
a lot of documents really our job is to
assist you
um in getting a document out getting a
budget out in the past from your
committee so you can see we like to keep
you organized on page 100 we like to put
together indexes of any amendments that
are provided so when the divisions
present to the full committee on here's
what we believe this portion of the
budget should be that everyone can
follow along will provide you with um
you know the section whether or not
there was an amendment if there was an
amendment uh and the recommendation will
include that and you can see on page 102
just kind of examples of what those
amendments look like we'll work with the
legislative services to develop those
amendments based on the discussions and
decisions you have in your Division and
then on page 104 it's very small I
apologize I kind of shrunk it down for
this presentation but this is our detail
chain sheet this is a document we'll
start the minute the house approves a
change to a one of the lines we'll make
sure that we keep track of this this is
something our analysts keep track of
internally as the house finance budgets
developed as well as the Senate and
Community Conference to ensure we're
tracking everything also to put some
comments in there of yes there's a um
175 and 225 000 Edition over the benium
but what is it for so we like to put you
know if you look on the budget document
the compare report doesn't really tell
you much the detail changes to really
provide a very high level but a little
more detail on like adding funding for
the Small Business Development Center
making a change because of a change to
maybe some employees but these changes
will add in foot to uh the compare
report which is a larger document
comparing so we think this is a very
helpful document for our office to keep
track of everything that the legislature
does but also for the legislature and
the public to keep it track could keep
track of what's been changing and that
is all I have for now
left a couple minutes excellent timing
and I rushed through a couple so for the
committee this reminds me of an old
military expression drinking from a fire
hose you're not getting much and a lot
of it's splashing around your ears but
um
these are these are handy things to hang
on to and if you want to refer back to
them and and of course you'll have your
your Genius experts in within each
division a little give you more details
as you need it but
um
I am so happy to be working with the LBA
all these years these these people do a
great job uh make us produce a great
product we couldn't do it without them
so I'm delighted to have all your people
here thank you
further questions about the material
too many to uh answer Jr go ahead thank
you Mr chairman uh page 94 so you're
giving us a 10-year look back right
regarding some level of funds right in
this case right this was the employees
yes how
at what level do you have that by
Department So within division three for
instance would you have that for DHHS as
a whole would you have that for within
divisions as a right how far down could
you do a statement like that
so that would require Health and Human
Services
um my guess is they should and have been
asked in the past to provide a history
by division uh by accounting unit of um
when I say accounting unit one function
of the number of employees so
they should be able to provide that to
you and historically have been able to
provide that thank you okay uh second
question
if if I could just add to that
um the the second strategic topic that
we're going to review in division three
is is Manpower where they're going to
break it down into that level and if
you're not satisfied with the breakdown
that they they come ready to give us we
we can ask them questions and we still
have a few weeks to get them to respond
so
thank you
um
second question page nine something here
to add I believe the budget actually has
the counts for every one of the
on page 96 if I'm reading this correctly
um the Departments have requested almost
16.3 billion dollars over the 24.25 is
that that is correct and that's jumping
from roughly 13 and a half in this
now representative memrick yes what
I still call it the kafir when are we
going to get the the printed so we have
hard copies ready to we'll bring them
over
um
probably later this week fiscal will
receive a um their hard copies on Friday
I mean before Friday I think this
Thursday is the mailing but we'll make
sure that uh we drop off with Janet uh
25 copies for all members as well so
any further questions
seeing none all right we're going to go
to your divisions at one o'clock and get
into more detail of what each division
will do and we have the experts here to
to guide you
thank you uh Mr Kane Mr true for backing
him up if he if needed and we'll see all
the rescue in divisions